our Season 22 winner of The Voice yes
yes another one thank you ma'am thank
you how does it feel you know it's just
incredible to be here and um it's like a
dream come true almost because I get to
be on that stage with this guy tonight
and then to be on stage and make my
family proud and make my home state
proud and everyone back home and it just
means the world to me that's what it's
all about and this is your ninth win as
a coach how will you celebrate
I
literally was just gonna say you've
already got the party started right here
I'm going to celebrate like this
strong yeah Bryce how are you gonna
celebrate you got a nice uh check coming
your way well you know um I see he's got
two over here but I need one that's full
because I'm gonna be celebrating the
same way okay okay
the wealth here yes ma'am now what is
next what do we say what do you say
about getting this guy an old red
residency
I don't think we can afford him now
that's the truth I mean it's like it's
funny I was I was actually texting with
the uh the manager of the old red and
actually in Oklahoma
and he goes uh he said uh uh
so we won't be able to afford Bryce but
who else can we get from this season I
thought well maybe Bryce will throw us a
solid but maybe maybe not now he's going
to be busy this guy's gonna be
I mean the the world's at his fingertips
right now that's what's most exciting
for me as a coach after the fact is is
no one after all this time I know what
opportunities are are coming his way and
uh you know people are people love the
guy I mean he won The Voice so imagine
how many people want to come see him in
concert now you know so there's there's
a lot out there for him but we're the
world at your
what I Hope's next is just making music
that people love people that make people
want to dance make people happy make
people want to cry so emotionally field
music that everyone loves with a with a
steel guitar and a fiddle in there
somewhere I was going to say spoken like
a true country artist now of course next
season is Blake's last what advice do
you have for the singers that are going
to be a part of his final season like I
said Blake is Blake's biggest piece of
advice for me is to be myself and I
would say to each and every artist be
who you are and and feel confident in
that and you can do anything in the
world
speaking of the final season Blake
tonight marked you and Gwen's final time
together on The Voice now she got
teary-eyed with me earlier I'm getting
teary-eyed just thinking about your
guys's journey together what is going
through your mind
I I was so wrapped up in the finale
tonight that
I mean I had three artists in the finale
and then and then Bryce won and
and I walked over to Gwen's chair after
after the cameras went off and and
she's over there literally sobbing and
she was like that's our last time we're
going to do this together you know and
and I don't think it's going to be
Gwen's last time to be a coach I
I would hope not for the for the sake of
the show uh but uh it will be the last
time she and I do this together and it
is crazy to think of of how you know the
show's changed my life but majorly by
meeting my wife you know as as being a
coach on this show so uh
I don't you know I was so wrapped up in
this that I didn't even think about that
and now you're trying to make me
emotional I know what you're trying to
do this is the Barbara Walters moment I
know what you're doing say it I
have carpets with
you about
Jing here on The Voice we we've got one
of our best love stories because of the
show
foreign
she says it and the name's the
microphone directly at my face so make
him cry I'll give you 20 bucks I know
what she's trying to do you're not gonna
make me cry you're not gonna make me cry
so here's the thing though you mentioned
like you hope it's not Gwen's last time
on the show what's gonna happen though
when she comes on the show and she
misses you and she wants to bring you
back as her team Mentor well I'd be
happy oh my God to be honored to be
Gwen's Mentor yeah
uh and uh whatever she tells me to do
I'm gonna do happy wife happy life
that's what they say that's it that's it
now this is a nice early Christmas
present this win for both of you holiday
plans what do you got coming up man you
know what I just want to curl up beside
a campfire outside enjoy the cold
weather a lot of good cigar and drink a
nice whiskey and just oh my God breath
and realize man you know I came here I
saw I conquered and I got to make this
guy proud and you know I gotta make my
family proud and just oh man
just God bless this experience man you
went from fighting for a spot to taking
home the whole thing I saw that I was
I'm the first Wild Card winner to ever
be a voice champion and um that's just
an honor and don't give up that's what I
say don't give up on your dreams don't
give up and always carry carry a big
stick and keep going forward absolutely
mic drop moment there last question for
you holiday plans
uh there's uh Christmas is coming up I
don't know if you knew that it's on the
December 25th yeah it's coming up pretty
quick
uh we're going to uh it's just going to
be a tour or just just
having Christmases with the family is a
tour within itself
I mean literally like a tour like oh now
we gotta go oh we got to be over there
you know what I mean so it's gonna be
crazy just like most most people out
there but uh it's our literally our
favorite time of year so we're excited
it's a good thing
good thing oh my God Barbara get it the
ratings are through the roof everyone
loves it can we get more
I hope we can get more uh I'm very busy
uh actually no I'm not I just I quit the
voice didn't I uh I I think we'll we'll
end up doing more of them I mean we it
was just a crazy absolutely ridiculous
stupid idea to begin with and and and
thank God that you know our friends you
know here at NBC USA Network they they
let us do it and and people like it you
know I think people were ready for
for something that they could watch and
not have to think so hard about and just
watch celebrities do stupid stuff and
and and and talk crap against each other
and that's all the show's ever going to
be and uh turns out people want to see
that who's the next celebrity we can get
on the show shoot your shot right now uh
well we have uh uh Taylor Swift and Paul
McCartney are going against each other
uh we have Garth Brooks uh and uh the
Pope okay are going against each other
just I don't want you know what I'm
giving away too much I don't you know
what that's next season I shouldn't be
giving tidbits here and we thought this
year's ratings were good oh it's gonna
be crazy next year yeah it's crazy
[Music]